Ach, ihr seid es nur.
Sagt das doch!
Herzlich Willkommen zu einem neuen Video.
Es geht heute um Rosmarin.
Und zwar darum, wie man aus Rosmarin Stecklinge
macht, um den zu vermehren.
Ich mache das super gerne, wenn ich zum Beispiel
bei Freunden zu Besuch bin und sehe, dass
die ganz tolle Kräuter haben.
Dann frage ich mal nach, ob ich mir davon
Stecklinge machen darf.
Und heute zeige ich euch eine ganz einfache
Methode, wie ihr diese Stecklinge verwurzeln
könnt, so dass ihr dann aus Stecklingen eure
eigenen Kräuter ziehen könnt.
Übrigens nicht wundern über meine Augenklappe.
Mir hat gestern beim Melken meine neue Milchziege
Cassia, die ihr aus dem Video hier oben kennt,
ihr Horn in mein Auge gerammt.
Die ist rückwärts zurück gewichen.
Das war also nicht böswillig.
Sie ist nur vor einer anderen Ziege zurück
gewichen und dabei ist das Horn leider in
meinem Auge gelandet.
Es ist aber nichts dauerhaft beschädigt.
Das muss jetzt nur wieder heilen.
Und dann ist hoffentlich bald alles wieder
gut.
Aber sprechen wir über Rosmarin.
Ich zeige euch jetzt, wie ihr Rosmarinstecklinge
ziehen könnt.
Das ist super einfach.
Ich packe euch in die Videobeschreibung auch
gerne mal eine Liste mit ganz vielen anderen
Kräutern, mit denen das genau so funktioniert.
Rosmarin ist jetzt hier nur unser Beispiel.
Es ist ein tolles Beispiel, weil es ein tolles
Kraut ist.
Aber es gibt noch viel mehr Kräuter, mit
denen das auch funktioniert.
Also schaut auf jeden Fall mal in der Videobeschreibung
vorbei.
Um den Rosmarin durch Stecklinge zu vermehren,
brichst du einfach einen mindestens fünfzehn
Zentimeter langen Zweig von der alten Pflanze
ab.
Das kann auch ein größerer Zweig sein.
Wir haben das schon sehr erfolgreich mit solchen
langen Zweigen gemacht, die unten auch schon
sehr verholzt waren.
Das ist also bei Rosmarin komplett egal, wie
alt der Zweig ist.
Er sollte aber fünfzehn Zentimeter lang sein,
denn wir werden jetzt die Blätter der unteren
fünf Zentimeter abmachen, so dass die nicht
faulen, wenn wir den Zweig gleich in ein Wasserglas
stellen.
Und da bleibt er dann stehen, ich mache das
immer in der Küche, bis sich feine, weiße
Wurzeln gebildet haben.
Da muss man immer nachschauen, dass das Wasser
immer aufgefüllt ist, weil wenn der austrocknet,
dann sterben die Wurzeln ab.
Ich habe vor ein paar Wochen schon mal einen
Rosmarinzweig ins Wasser gestellt.
Der ist jetzt fertig.
Der kann jetzt gepflanzt werden.
Da haben sich tolle weiße Würzelchen gebildet.
Und den pflanzen wir jetzt ins Beet.
Da einfach ein Loch ausheben, das so tief
ist wie der Wurzelballen.
Die Pflanze gut andrücken, gut angießen.
Ich habe dem jetzt auch noch hier so ein kleines
Stützholz gegeben, weil das schon ein längerer
Zweig ist.
Damit der nicht umkippt.
Und dann den Boden um die Pflanze herum über
längere Zeit gut feucht halten, damit die
Wurzeln gut anwachsen können.
Ich lege nach dem Pflanzen immer noch einen
Gießrand an um die Pflanze.
Also einen kleinen Graben, einen flachen kleinen
Graben um die Pflanze drumherum.
So dass, wenn man gießt, das Gießwasser
schön bei der Pflanze bleibt und nicht wegläuft.
Das mache ich mit allen Jungpflanzen so, die
ich neu pflanze, damit das Gießen eben schneller
geht und das Wasser auch da bleibt, wo es
hin soll.
Die Frage, wo man Kräuter hin pflanzen soll,
kommt immer wieder.
Rosmarin mag es sehr sonnig.
Das ist ein mediterranes Kraut.
Das mag es gerne in einem vollsonnigen Beet.
Andere Kräuter wachsen aber lieber im Schatten
oder im Halbschatten.
Da solltest du also vorher einmal nachschauen,
bevor du Kräuter pflanzt, was die denn so
für Ansprüche haben.
Rosmarin mag es lieber auf einem trockeneren
Boden zu wachsen, während zum Beispiel Schnittlauch
es schon wieder ein bisschen feuchter mag.
Da gibt es also ganz unterschiedliche Ansprüche.
Und dementsprechend positioniere ich dann
meine Kräuter in meinem Garten.
Also ich überlege mir immer, was wäre die
beste Ecke jetzt für dieses Kraut, damit
es optimal wachsen kann.
Außerdem bepflanze ich am allerliebsten meine
Beetränder mit den Kräutern, gerade so am
Weg entlang finde ich das super schön.
Und viele Kräuter haben ja auch einen starken
Geruch, der Schädlinge fern halten kann.
Deswegen bepflanze ich immer meine Gemüsebeete
mit den Kräutern, damit wir da eben noch
so einen schönen Mischkultureffekt haben.
Man kann aber natürlich auch ein ganz eigenes
Kräuterbeet oder eine Kräuterschnecke anlegen.
Das ist auch eine super Idee.
Wenn euch das Video gefallen hat, dann gebt
ihm gerne einen Daumen nach oben.
Ich freue mich auch, wenn ihr den Kanal abonniert.
Ich werde auch mehr Kräutervideos machen.
Haben wir in Planung.
Wir werden bald über Basilikum ein Video
machen.
Das kann ich euch gerne da oben verlinken,
sobald das erscheint.
Hier drüben und da unten findet ihr auch
noch spannende Videos, die euch interessieren
könnten.
Ich freue mich, wenn wir uns da wiedersehen.
Ansonsten bis nächste Woche.
Tschüss!